all that is gold does not glitter
not all those who wander are lost
the old that is strong does not wither
deep roots are not reached by the frost
we don't choose the time that we live in
we can only decide how to live in the
times that have chosen us
being a child and continuing to believe
in dreams and fairy tales as an adult is
true wisdom
become even wiser with JRR Tolkien by
listening to his best sayings
faithless is he that says farewell when
the road darkens
the world is full enough of hurts and
Miss chances
without Wars to multiply them
a man that flies from his fear may find
that he has only taken a shortcut to
meet it
shortcuts make long delays
any riddles solved then seems
surprisingly easy
fair speech May hide a foul heart
it is not the strength of the body that
counts
the strength of the spirit
where there's life There's Hope
courage is found in unlikely places
defeat inevitability awaits only those
who despair in advance
all's well that ends better
there is more good in you than you know
there is no Victory without suffering
false hopes are more dangerous than
fears
and the most skillful spider allows
slack in his web
even the smallest person can change the
course of the future
I'm talking aloud to myself a lot
a habit of the old
they choose the wisest person present to
speak to
the why speak only of what they know
luck is a tricky thing
don't tempt it
how do you move on
you move on when your heart finally
understands that there is no turning
back
you can only come to the morning through
the Shadows
there are wounds that will never fully
heal
if you don't have kids after 30
it means that the message hasn't been
sent after all
children are living messages that we
send at a time that we will never be
able to see
it is useless to meet Revenge with
Revenge
it will heal nothing
do not complicate your life with belated
regrets
you cannot be a tyrant and an advisor at
the same time
dissolving untimely rumors is always
dangerous
they can go to the wrong address
in order to unleash a war the desire of
one side is enough
let him not vow to walk in the dark who
has not seen the Nightfall
falsehood in an immortal and
indestructible seed again and again it
sprouts
and will bear black fruit until the last
days
a strange thing about everything good
about the days that you spend pleasantly
is told very quickly and listening to
them is not so interesting
but about the unpleasant which causes
fear or disgust the stories are long and
exciting
the less you show curiosity along the
way
the less likely you are to get into
trouble
when the wise are powerless
help comes from the weak
praise from the praiseworthy is beyond
all Rewards
it is hard to believe that fire burns
until you touch it
oft hope is born when all is forlorn
pride in a difficult hour rejecting both
help and advice is truly senseless and
insane
may your courage be a light to you in
Dark Places
when all other lights go out
there is nothing like looking
if you want to find something you
certainly usually find something
if you look but it is not always quite
the something you were after
evil sets in motion enormous forces with
constant success
but only in vain
it only prepares the ground on which
unexpected goodness will sprout
all have their worth and each
contributes to the worth of the others
for the small as well as for the great
there are Deeds that they can only do
once and their Spirit lives in these
Deeds
there are some things that it is better
to begin than to refuse
even though the end may be dark
Moonlight drowns out all but the
brightest stars
if more of us valued food and cheer and
song Above hoarded gold
it would be a merrier world
even the very wise cannot see all ends
you should not say Do not weep
for not all tears are evil
there is hope
and love will win where armies fail
and if love is powerless
then nothing will win
but why live then
living by faith includes the call to
something greater than cowardly
self-preservation
the world is indeed full of dangers and
there is a lot of darkness in it
but a lot of beauty
there is no such place where love would
not be overshadowed by grief
but doesn't it only become stronger from
this
we have tried to collect J.R.R tolkien's
quotes that will awaken an inner child
and a true Miracle believer in you his
quotes illustrate his creative religious
and inspirational side thank you for
watching